So I've noted this a few times already.
If we are going to deal with the current pandemic
in a way that would even come close to being
called successful and again, now when we talk
about success, we're talking about how much
can we limit the number of people who die
because the number is climbing rapidly.
And it's it's a question of limiting that
number.
Sadly, if we're going to deal with it in anything
that would approximate a success, it's going
to likely depend on our state governors.
It's not going to happen because Donald Trump's
direction give some kind of unified and and
well sit well appointed, well crafted strategy.
And in fact, we're seeing Donald Trump increasingly
push in the other direction.
It's becoming very much obvious that Donald
Trump is all but completely committed to reopening
the country, letting it rip, as Dr. Anthony
Foushee sort of characterized it on Easter
Sunday, April 12th.
Now, it's still possible that the numbers
will be so ugly by that point.
And we'll look at the numbers later.
And it seems to be going in that direction.
It's possible that the numbers will be so
ugly that Donald Trump will be talked out
of it, even by people as incompetent as Jared
Kushner, who apparently has a hand in everything
he's supposedly going to not not only is he
going to fix the Israeli-Palestinian conflict,
Jared Kushner's expected, I guess, to deal
with coronavirus as well, despite having no
experience whatsoever in infectious disease.
And we've been thinking about how different
state governors are likely to react to Donald
Trump wanting to let it rip on April 12th.
Because remember, still now, at nearly the
end of March, more than half of state governors
have done nothing yet.
As of two days ago, 30 of 50 states had no
state level directives about shutting down
nonessential businesses.
Self-isolation, staying home, schools, et
cetera.
Now, many of those states had individual cities
that may have made such determinations.
But 30 of 50, that's 60 percent, right?
That's three fifths.
Weren't even doing anything yet.
Imagine the insanity of talking about let's
open it back up when 30 states haven't yet
even closed anything down.
It's completely crazy.
So when they talk about April 12th, understand
that many states, nothing's changed.
Those states are just standing by and is business
as usual, which makes this all the more absurd.
They're going to reopen from never having
closed.
But the most important thing here is if there
is anything positive and we're desperately
looking for silver linings every day and there
aren't many, it does seem that more and more
governors are just not going to follow Donald
Trump's direction.
They are going to say no to Donald Trump and
they're going to do what's right for their
state, which is likely to stay shut down for
what is unfortunately a relatively long period
of time.
We've got New York Governor Andrew Cuomo clearly
not on the same page as Donald Trump.
And talking about more closures, more limitations
as we get into April and eventually going
going into May.
California Governor Gavin Newsom, he's very
clearly operating under a completely different
sort of set of facts based on the last thing
he said, the extension of stay at home orders
in California.
It's going to go for a while, even in Texas,
where Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick has
been completely unhinged and talking about
sacrificing grandparents in order to save
the stock market for for their grandchildren.
You even have the governor there, Texas Republican
Governor Greg Abbott, who's pretty bad.
He now is at least endorsing the stay at home
orders that individual cities in Texas have
put in place.
I know it's not that much they're doing it
anyway.
Doesn't change anything that Greg Abbott endorses
it, but it is a good sign.
And then you've got Arizona Governor Doug
Doocy, who says public health must come before
the economy.
Yeah, that's true.
South Dakota Governor Kristi Noem says business
activity must be limited, not relaxed at this
time.
And in many ways, this is going to become
and it is a story already about states rights
vs. the federal government, which is an issue
that it's an issue that is a common political
debate.
But I certainly didn't expect on day one of
this fiasco that one of the greatest determinants
as to how this goes was going to be the issue
of states rights versus the federal government.
And it probably wouldn't be the issue if we
had competent science based leadership coming
from the Oval Office rather than doctors stand
onstage, but they basically shut their mouths
while Donald Trump brags about this.
That and the other thing that he claims he
did while sometimes during these press briefings,
not even talking about the case numbers or
the death toll, it's very difficult to imagine
now thinking about Massachusetts.
I don't see Republican Massachusetts governor.
Charlie Baker and a lot of other governors
jumping on board with April 12th, especially
when we are hearing about more school closures,
more business closures, extending the school
closures here in Massachusetts and in other
places, and especially when you look at the
numbers, which we will look at later.
I hope that governors will will maintain sanity.
Now, interestingly enough, the governor of
Mississippi, Tate Reeves, he's going crazy
to stop abortions during the Corona virus
pandemic.
But he's very much welcome welcoming the idea
of a wide open on April 12th.
We know, of course, that Mississippi's health
system is a disaster.
We know that the underlying health conditions
impact coronavirus mortality rates drastically.
It could very quickly get very, very ugly
in Mississippi for Tate Reeves.
Well, we'll be watching that.
And then there are even discussions starting
about the possibility of states actually putting
in checkpoints at their own borders.
Imagine, for example, that you have certain
states that are all in with we've got a distance,
whereas other states are all about let it
rip.
You could conceivably have state governors
wanting to set up checkpoints at their borders,
which is a very complicated legal thing to
do in the United States.
Freedom of movement between states is determined
by what's called the privileges and immunities
clause of the Constitution.
And it is a pretty significant restriction
on states being able to erect barriers or
block entry to states.
Free movement between states is in the Constitution.
It's very difficult to do that.
If it gets to that point, imagine that Louisiana
takes it seriously.
But you know, Alabama doesn't or whatever.
You could very quickly see that hypothetical
conflict become a very real legal conflict
in some of these states.
Last thing I want to come back to you here
from the beginning, right wing media choosing
to entertain Donald Trump's completely delusional
perspective on all of this has done such drastic
and permanent damage.
It has led to nearly half the country or more
than half the country by states, maybe not
by population, to essentially believe that
this is no big deal, that it is going to kind
of just take care of itself.
We don't have to do anything that is a belief
that will increase the death toll.
The death toll is already higher than it otherwise
would be if every state back in whatever the
date was, March 15th or so were more and more
states started taking this seriously, had
said we're going to shut the whole thing down.
Now, Donald Trump seems increasingly indifferent
to the death toll.
He instead, during his press conference, talks
about stock market, how much money he's gonna
give businesses, how quickly he can get businesses
reopened.
No mention sometimes of the death toll, even
if testing there's barely mentioning sometimes
until Donald Trump now got his hands on this
talking point of we've tested more people
in eight days than South Korea did in the
previous eight weeks or something.
Of course, ignoring the fact that we're a
far larger country with many more people.
We're in real trouble here.
And I'm hoping because we're desperate for
some kind of silver lining.
I'm hoping governors will help.
Except they've got to all get on the same
page.
And right now, they are not 20 governors doing
something, 30 governors doing nothing.